the mistake that the virtual reality
people have made is they think that
resolution is the point resolution is
not the point Tetris is unbelievably low
resolution and it works because it's low
resolution virtual reality is going to
start to work when they go to really
really low resolution in my head snow
crash is a low resolution simulation of
the earth it's not real life that's why
it worked because the same way the
houses and Monopoly aren't real houses
and the horses in chess aren't real
horses that metaphor enables us to alert
the right part of our brain right now
virtual reality is in The Uncanny Valley
and The Uncanny Valley immediately
repulses almost everybody